and ponder the question
what if
time being wasted
space hang out reality is that i've
already hit the skip intro prompt
because this intro was boring the first
time i saw it let alone the fourth we
have watched how one moment one choice
watcheration so much wateration what if
the best of intentions
has very strange consequences if you're
going to doctor the wording for puns
don't do that ancient one at a time
thing you really need to throw a few
supreme turns of phrase in there to
really make it all even steven the
question is how many more dough scissor
doors too many people learned the wrong
lessons from back to the future evening
handsome this i just pulled it out of
the dryer what does this even mean how
would putting an item of clothing in the
dryer make it any less impressive do
most people in new york wear wet clothes
you promised me creme brulee
i suspect we can do a little better than
that for someone who brags about putting
a suit in a dryer i'm a little afraid to
find out what dr strange considers a
little better i just stick with the
creme brulee doc she's not gonna find
the frosted animal cookie blizzard as
charming as you do strange slows his
vehicle down and the guy behind him
rear-ends him in a skid steven's car
then does a full turn significantly
broadsides a pole does another turn and
a half and still somehow breaks through
the rock guard barrier with enough
momentum to launch 10 feet out over the
cliff joe doesn't know how to law of
conservation of energy correctly in this
universe steven strange didn't lose his
hands
but his heart roll commercial show title
is completely invalid he didn't lose his
hands before he lost his use of them and
that's not his heart that's his dead
girlfriend in a box and the director
said let's do that mystical apple eating
thing again so the audience will know
we're [ __ ] for only changing the
things we want to in the timeline
because callbacks steven strange
could not let go of the past wonderful
instead of christine being ignored
underused and wasted this time we're
going to have her be completely fridged
for motivational purposes such progress
sorry but this is now my favorite
t-shirt stealing what are you doing up i
needed the little sorceress room calling
it your little sorcerer you're being
delightful
i must owe someone a muffin basket for
this personality shift calling it your
muffin basket well this is shaping up to
be a night to remember
we find out eventually it doesn't matter
but how does strange go back to stop
this from happening and still get
rear-ended at the exact same place in
the road with the same pole and same
weak ass guard wall why wait till the
second try to go ahead and have google
maps find a route that i don't know
doesn't involve the death cliff and one
job strange also just going to go ahead
and add 10 sins because this groundhog
day sorcery goes on for all the some
time
we'll go we'll dance i promise you we
will have a good time
no what even happens here she has some
sort of medical event like maybe a heart
thing it's clear the universe needs her
to die but if it's already going for
cardiac arrest and an otherwise healthy
young woman shouldn't strange know he
can't change anything at this point how
do you go back in time to avoid random
health issue that could happen anywhere
also they made it there to dance how did
they do that does the universe have a
bit of leeway on the timeline what's the
christine must die window anyone have a
direct number for the tva and now we're
back in the water below the same exact
cliff again you went back to trying to
drive the same route i guess there's
nothing you can do sometimes people just
pick a hill to die one
dr christine palmer fatalistic news
position fatalist position also not only
does the universe decide to take out
numerous people to get to christine but
the local news decides that she's worth
soloing as an immediate eulogy is she
that famous in new york city why does
this keep happening maybe because you
keep coming back to this point in time
maybe he can't change the outcome
regardless but you'd think strange would
attempt one trip to a time prior to this
night do you want to talk
maybe put on some music
maybe warner about the car that's about
to crash into her that you know is
coming
[Music]
no good evening doctor strange
are you having car trouble
oh snap more like the [ __ ] one am i
right also why is she just coming now
her and wong made it clear that [ __ ]
around with time travel is a bad idea so
if the ancient one could come to him and
prevent all of this why would she wait
this long her death
is an absolute point in time in this
universe you mean because it certainly
didn't happen this way and the other one
maybe strange shouldn't be looking at
time travel but should be looking at
multiverse oh
there is no hope here right so then does
he just what come back with you to your
timeline live out the rest of this
timeline go to one of the numerous
timelines he's already created and what
timeline are you even from how does any
of this even work where did you come
from where does he go where did you come
from plot and lie joe library
hello
you know books
reading
knowledge that's racist the lost books
source of reading do you mind sharing a
tentacle or two attempting to share
someone's tentacle even if you're asking
for explicit consent it's kind of
strange strange strange survives this
when red skull didn't
what happened well even though you got
strewn about by a giant octopus monster
not only are you not showing any wear or
tear the bruce you had earlier on your
forehead is also miraculously gone a man
does not suffer like this for his own
glory
[Laughter]
yeah humans are much more likely to
suffer for others than themselves super
unselfish this species if they won't
surrender their power i'll take it
let's start small so this episode is
basically what if doctor strange
murdered an insane amount of fantastical
creatures well that's fun for the kids
every one of these creatures feels like
an inside joke i'm probably missing it's
like lego batman all over again and i'm
all like haha can you imagine if there
was a condiment based villain and
everyone else was like well there is and
i was like yeah comic books totally why
did the dragon turn them all dragon face
but the garden gnome didn't give him a
fishing pole and a visible butt crack
you use magic to remain frozen for
centuries nope that's a different disney
property everything is a different
disney property he wasn't even the only
doctor strange in this universe i would
give all the synths back if we get a
time cop face melt when the two versions
of steven strange meet
what was in that whiskey dude people's
faces are inking off and you're cracking
wise what do you think you're healing
the world with your comedy yes just
think of me as an echo
i drew upon the power of the dark
dimension to split the timeline
to split you sure i guess but you split
the strange who was already trying to
change the past into half who continued
on that journey and then half that went
back in time and forgot all that stuff
just say yada yada next time and save us
all the headache i mean we're gonna send
you either way but i prefer the
non-headache way two timelines i doubt
that's the simplest or smartest thing to
do steven strange would be magical at tv
sins how would you find him
he's found me convenient timing of evil
strange finding not as evil strange is
convenient hello episode is 14 someone
saying hello and randomly adele's
favorite episode don't you dare lie to
me i am you yeah i know here's a what if
for you what if marvel took one of their
films that somehow didn't end in same
versus same and decided to make it into
a tv episode that did end that way
marvel's got a marvel i guess episode
ends with one minute and 50 seconds of
sorcery pew pewing
i live i die i live again i think you
should just rush the podium like a
contestant on the price is right the
price is wrong [ __ ]
we're okay
you're okay i'm gonna be okay
say the word christine and i will give
you the world you you want the moon just
say the word and i'll throw a lasso
around and pull it down
well
we're back
in the car again
i only require more power with great
power
comes great responsibility